la pologne est inquiète les grèves c'est
ans moscou
irrité un souhait de valéry giscard
d'estaing la pologne doit surmonter elle
même ses difficultés
bayrou tout un festival français sans un
rappel pour chéreau et boulez madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
la pologne est situé dans la zone de
sécurité de l'union soviétique
la situation de notre pays s'est
développé dans une direction dangereuse
il reste impossible d'affirmer que le
cours des événements qui est de nature à
mener le pays à une catastrophe
nationale et été arrêté
tous les polonais ont pu lire ce matin
dans tribunal ou d'où le journal du
parti ces quelques phrases écrites par
un des membres du comité central
monsieur voïna à varsovie le pouvoir
s'inquiètent de la tournure prise par
les événements la situation lui échappe
et même le discours prononcé hier et
très exceptionnellement retransmis à la
télévision du cardinal primat de pologne
n'a pas eu l'effet escompté
c'est à dire la reprise du travail au
contraire après les ports de la baltique
et stettin aujourd'hui lot
evreux clôt ainsi que d'autres cités
industrielles sont touchés les
négociations pourtant repris après 18
heures d'interruption mais elles sont
très difficiles alors regardez ces
images nous allons entrer dans le
chantier naval lénine c'est à gdansk
le dialogue va commencer les ouvriers
sont présents ils vont suivre toute la
discussion d'hier soir c'est de ses
auditeurs attentifs et grave cette foule
immobile dans un décor qui déjà nous est
familier les travailleurs des chantiers
navals baltes pendant les pourparlers
avec l'envoyé de varsovie filière depuis
deux semaines maintenant ils attendent
que leur revendication économique mais
également politique trouve un accueil
concret le fait que les laborieux débat
qui avait lieu à l'intérieur des
bâtiments est été retranscrit au dehors
et même par la radio régionale était en
soi une victoire
interrompue à nouveau par
l'interlocuteur gouvernementale monsieur
yahiel ce qui rappelait dans la capitale
par la réunion du bureau politique
les pourparlers qui ont repris cet
après-midi en petit comité avait
débouché en partie si la création de
syndicats autonomes n'a pas été obtenu
le droit de grève en revance est acquis
un pas déterminant dans le bras de fer
engagé par les travailleurs polonais
avec les dirigeants de leur pays
quant aux revendications purement
matérielles elles ont été largement
écouté pour ce qui concerne les salaires
la politique du logement et le
ravitaillement mais a déclaré monsieur
yaguine ce qui tout n'est pas possible
tout de suite et les progrès devront
intervenir par étapes
compte tenu de l'endettement et du bas
niveau économique actuelle de la pologne
pour la première fois d'ailleurs
l'organe du pc tribunal ou doux a évoqué
aujourd'hui le danger d'une intervention
soviétique en soulignant le rôle
stratégique de la pologne en europe
on ne peut affirmer écrit l'auteur
richard bona que le cours des événements
qui est de nature à mener le pays au
pire est été arrêté malgré cela et
malgré l'appel à la reprise du travail
émanant du primat de pologne
le cardinal vie chinsky la combativité
n'a pas faibli la grève a même gagné
deux nouvelles régions notamment celle
de l'ubs l'un et de nouvelles villes
comme co chaline et cracovie donne en
plus d'ampleur géographique au mouvement
oui cette séance de négociations a
glance interrompu hier soir a donc
repris cet après midi à 16 heures et
elle se poursuit actuellement les
communications restent extrêmement
difficile avec la pologne josh fox lie
vient pourtant de réussir à entrer en
contact avec varsovie dans un studio de
la télévision polonaise
andré bilic présentateur et rédacteur en
chef de cette télévision polonaise grecs
ont accusé hier soir par ce matin même
par tribunal au dos qui était
extrêmement à la remise sur le plan
international qui parlait d'une
situation alarmante pour la pologne ont
craint une intervention soviétique
non je ne pense pas qu'on craint en
pologne l'intervention soviétique
derrière là les agents soviétiques les
commentaires officiels soviétique a été
absolument clair à ce train là je te
laisse pas permet de vous arrêter parce
qu'il ya un commentaire de ta ce qui
nous arrive à l'instant
lagence tu as raison soviétique dénonce
aujourd'hui l'activité subversives des
éléments anti socialiste en pologne ça
vous paraît pas inquiétant écoutez je ne
connais pas ces commentaires encore il
faudrait que je réalise que je les vois
exactement mais de toute façon je puis
vous dire aussi que par exemple monsieur
leonid brejnev est aujourd'hui à
alma-ata il a quitté moscou pour alma
ata donc en jugeant la situation
européenne satisfaisante si vous voulez
nous avons tous été très frappé sur un
autre plan par le fait que la télévision
polonaise était ouverte et hier soir une
homélie du cardinal buts inscrits ce qui
est inhabituel
nous avons été frappés par le fait que
le cardinal a lancé un appel à la
sagesse ouvriers aux ouvriers
qu'apparemment il n'a pas été entendu
alors est ce que vraiment le
gouvernement les autorités ont essayé de
s'appuyer sur l'église dans cette
circonstance difficile et coûteux bien
sûr c'est à dire que nous sommes prêts
absolument les pouvoirs si vous voulez
les autres et polonais nous sommes prêts
absolument à s'appuyer sur toutes les
forces de la nation qui sont pour les
calmes qu'ils font n'est ce pas pour la
solution de nos problèmes pourquoi pas
l'église
vous n'avez pas l'impression que les
autorités brûle un peu leurs dernières
cartouches et l encens a demandé appui
au gardien revisite si je ne le pense
pas sincèrement voyez vous si vous dites
que cet appel n'a pas était tout à fait
entendu ça veut dire que les rôles de
l'église n'est pas appel peut-être qu'on
le pense c'est à dire les rôles de
l'église est très important dans pologne
quand
il s'agit parfois d'inaction contre
n'êtes pas destructive mais quand il
s'agit de quel de faire de quelque chose
d'être très constructive par rapport à
l'opinion publique ça devient un peu
plus compliquer un peu plus complexes
souvent des ligues depuis la dernière
fois que nous nous sommes parlé c'est la
seule la semaine dernière beaucoup de
choses ont changé en pologne beaucoup de
choses et beaucoup de gens ont cisaillé
responsable impression à varsovie d'un
changement profond qui est en route tout
en couvrant je pense sincèrement que
nous sommes en train de vivre des jours
très très important très décisive dans
le sens d'une démocratisation profonde
des systèmes polonais lé défi scène
socialiste polonais alors ces jours là
vraiment me semble très importante
je vous remercie beaucoup même si j'en
ai très importante donc en pologne mais
inquiétudes aussi en occident le
président giscard d'estaing a souhaité
ce matin que la pologne puisse trouver
en elle-même les moyens de surmonter ses
difficultés et de répondre aux
aspirations de son peuple
l'existence et le rôle de la pologne
déclare aussi le chef de l'état avait
une importance fondamentale pour l'
équilibre et la fête de l'europe pour
cette prise de position
la première depuis le début des
événements en pologne le chef de l'état
avait choisi le cadre solennel du
conseil des ministres d'autant plus
solennel d'ailleurs qu'il marquait le
quatrième anniversaire de l'arrivée à
matignon de monsieur raymond barre le
président de la république a profité de
cet anniversaire pour a signé quatre
objectifs au gouvernement la ligne de
l'action a dit le président de la
république à monsieur raymond barre doit
être hardiment conçu clairement classés
et conduite avec fermeté dans le respect
de la solidarité et de la liberté des
français à l'issue du déjeuner qui a
suivi ce conseil le chef de l'état
félicité le premier ministre pour le
travail tenace et clairvoyant accompli
depuis quatre ans la pêche à l'elysée ce
matin on ne devait pas en débattre
longuement mais on en a tout de même par
une approbation pour les mesures
annoncées hier par monsieur joël le
theule est aussi une confirmation le
gouvernement maintiendra la libre
circulation et navigation dans les ports
sur place d'ailleurs aux deux points
névralgiques c'est-à-dire fausses et
antifer les marins pêcheurs ont
finalement renoncé point sensible
aujourd'hui boulogne-sur-mer ce sont les
transports
le gouvernement maintiendra la libre
circulation et navigation dans les ports
sur place d'ailleurs aux deux points
névralgiques c'est-à-dire fausses et
antifer les marins pêcheurs ont
finalement renoncé point sensible
aujourd'hui boulogne sur mer ce sont les
transporteurs routiers qui se sont mis
en colère
depuis ce matin ils bloquent totalement
la ville le fort et isolée par des
camions les grands axes routiers sont
coupés
seuls les pompiers et les ambulances et
les médecins pouvaient circuler puis en
fin d'après midi
et vous voyez ces images ce sont les
marins pêcheurs qui sont dans 108
descendus dans la rue dominique laurier
pascal stelletta ont passé toute la
journée à boulogne sur mer
ici les choses se compliquent à la
paralysie du port s'ajoute aujourd'hui
le blocus de la ville
en effet après la rupture hier des
négociations des poids lourds blocs à
leur tour les principales routes les
transporteurs soutenu par les
industriels de la pêche volt ainsi
protester contre distille une atteinte à
la liberté du travail car les grévistes
interdisent toute sortie du poisson
parfois piquet de grève des marins
pêcheurs et transporter son face à face
pas d'incident mais une tension
difficile et surtout la colère
tout le monde est bloqué tout le monde
at asphyxié vous donne va disparaître
financièrement on a plus on n'a plus
rien de plus rien physiquement ce blocus
spectaculaire s'est étendu rapidement à
l'ensemble de boulogne au port où tout
est arrêté au centre-ville où les
grandes rues sont fermées à la
circulation et enfin aux principales
routes à l'entrée de la ville au total
près de 100 poids lourds paralyse la
cité un spectacle qui commence à
inquiéter sérieusement la population
mais pour les transporteurs le maire
pour qu'une certaine responsabilité dans
la situation où il y a dans le quartier
industriel 40 camions qui sont bloquées
depuis 15 jours il y a des plusieurs
dizaines cuisine qui sont fermés cinq
mille travailleurs qui ne peuvent pas
travailler parce qu' une poignée de 50
marins ont établi des piquets qui
interdisent la libre circulation dans la
zone portuaire même précipité vers la
zone industrielle ont dit barrick aaron
des barricades
tamedia nous il y a dans la zone
industrielle des otages me dont le maire
de boulogne ne se soucie absolument pas
depuis 15 ans et puis ils ont
l'impression que c'est moi qui suis
responsable je le dis une fois de plus
c'est le gouvernement qui est
responsable mes propos soient claires et
je suis étonné de voir que les
transporteurs souhaitent qu'on amène ici
25 compagnies de crs de manière à ce que
le tout dégénère en émeute
non je prends mes responsabilités mais
responsabilité c'est de tout faire pour
que effectivement il n'y a pas de sens
on en est là actuellement dont je crois
que ce que je vais faire c'est continuer
les négociations c'est-à-dire essayer de
servir d'intermédiaire entre les deux
parties de manière à ce que l'on puisse
cohabiter
pas question de faire appel aux forces
de l'ordre affirment les transporteurs
nous voulons simplement pouvoir circuler
librement dans boulogne et travailler
malgré cette tension et quelques
manifestations en fin de journée des
négociations se déroulent actuellement
entre les transporteurs les marins
pêcheurs et le sous préfet chacun est
conscient ici que ce blocus
est une vraie poudrière dans les ports
fossé antifer ont donc été dégagée hier
soir et cette nuit le port de dunkerque
est ce c'est à dire le port de
marchandises de dunkerque a lui aussi
été rendu à la libre navigation en
revanche à dieppe des bagarres ont
opposé marins pêcheurs et forces de
l'ordre alors le point sur ce conflit
jean marc et nous voici le
jean-dominique chalutier endommagés au
cours d'une collision alors qu'ils
tentaient de s'opposer aux navires de la
marine nationale qui pour la seconde
fois depuis jeudi ont dégagé ce matin
très tôt le port de fos
avec l'aide des gendarmes mobiles aux
jets de pierres et de boue l'on attribué
aux marins ont répondu les tirs des
gendarmes grenades lacrymogènes et
offensives assurent les marins ce que
dément la préfecture quatre blessés en
tous cas chez les marins dont un seul
reste hospitalisé aujourd'hui pour
éviter aux marins les dangers de
nouveaux affrontements semblables les
pêcheurs de la région ont décidé de ne
plus dressé des barrages dans le secteur
pétrolier ils se concertent jusqu'à
demain matin pour mettre au point une
nouvelle tactique et les autorités
maritimes déclare redouter un nouveau
durcissement presque depuis 7h ce matin
le trafic a repris à fos par ailleurs de
brefs affrontements ont opposé marin et
gendarmes à diop d intervention
qualifiée de répression intolérable je
cite par le parti communiste et edmond
maire écrit à raymond barre et lui
demande de faire cesser de telles
interventions
alors si ce soir les syndicats annoncent
qu'ils participeront demain à la seconde
réunion nationale de conciliation sur le
conflit de boulogne les positions
restent aussi tranchée que celle qui ont
entraîné l'échec de la première réunion
d'avant-hier
où
monsieur livre l'ancien qui est député
rpr de paris demandent la création d'un
grand ministère de la mer monsieur
crépeau le président du mouvement des
radicaux de gauche fait la même demande
le maire de la rochelle préconise aussi
un plan de relance qui porterait sur la
gestion des stocks de poissons la
réforme du crédit maritime et
l'adaptation de la pêche aux conditions
de moderne
enfin puisque ce conflit dépend aussi
beaucoup de ce qui se passe en europe
monsieur le theule a écrit à bruxelles
le ministre des transports demande d'une
accélération des travaux devant aboutir
un véritable marché commun de la pêche
les organes du marché commun sont encore
en vacances pas de réponse donc avant la
semaine prochaine
mais d'ores et déjà la commission
européenne s'est prononcé contre toute
subvention sur le gaz
alors reste aujourd'hui les touristes
pour ceux de l'île de ré la situation
s'améliore lentement le trafic était
normal aujourd'hui mais il ya encore
beaucoup de délai pour rejoindre le
continent
les files d'attentes devrait toutefois
se résorber au cours de la nuit au havre
bernard pradines lui a rencontré les
professionnels du tourisme pendant
quinze jours le port du havre on a eu
aucune activité ou presque pas de
pétroliers 70 % de son trafic pas de
marchandise pertes quotidiennes 5
millions de francs pour la direction du
port des milliers de conteneurs ont été
détournés sur anvers ou rotterdam
les transporteurs de produits
alimentaires s'estime lourdement
pénalisé ouvriers des contenaires qui
sont ici
et qui auraient dû partir il ya trois
semaines de doute les deux qui sont ici
à 2,20 pied puis un gros 40 pieds là
derrière qui sont pleins de marchandises
on n'ose pas les ouvrir parce que c'est
de la marchandise qui souffrent et
normalement pense qu'ils seront expédiés
pas avant le 2 4 le havre
ce n'est pas seulement un port pétrolier
de marchandises aussi le troisième porte
passager français après calais et
boulogne
un million de personnes par an plusieurs
départs quotidiens pour la grande
bretagne
autant dire que les hôteliers les
restaurateurs ont de quoi faire
d'habitude ils ne se plaignent pas
aujourd'hui après quinze jours de blocus
qui sont beaucoup moins contents nous
avions environ et 40 à 45 personnes par
jour de prévu et nous nous retrouvons
avec 6 8 10 11 petit déjeuner le matin
on a eu quand même une
non un manque de clientèle sur les
surtout d'anglais par l'interruption des
ferries
et une forte augmentation des prix du
poisson one x 100 m brasse on est donc
automatiquement plus cher les touristes
de passage
les anglais principalement vont
maintenant prendre le bateau en belgique
là encore les conséquences de la grève
des pêcheurs sont sensibles en période
touristique nous transportons jusqu'à 3
à 4000 passagers par jour du fait du
déroutage sur le port de zeebrugge bien
at war ii nous en avons perdu en route
les habitants du havre ne porte pas de
jugement sur la grève des pêcheurs ils
la comprennent
mais jusqu'à un certain point en gros on
reproche aux pêcheurs d'en avoir trop
fait ce que nous avons du mal à
compenser qui les enjoint arrivé à
bloquer la totalit la totalité de
l'activité portuaire
marchât xavier des conséquences pour
tout le monde finalement inévitablement
car il n'y a pas que le tourisme qui
soit touchée la réparation navale
également ainsi que plusieurs
professions qui dépendent de l'activité
du port depuis ce matin les bateaux
passent à nouveau 15 jours d'arrêt m'a
dit le pdg du port du havre
cela n'est pas irrécupérable en raison
du conseil des ministres qui se tenait
ce matin les marins pêcheurs attendait
beaucoup de cette journée mais le
gouvernement s'est montré finalement
assez peu disert alors philippe sassier
comment est-ce que l'on peut expliquer
cette attitude ou l'inventeur et le
communiqué du conseil des ministres est
très clair il s'agit a bullet faire pour
la pêche industrielle d'un conflit
interne à la profession la solution doit
être recherchée entre les négociations
par les négociations entre armateurs et
marne alors certains ont été déçus ou
surpris devant ce laconisme ministériels
parce que l'on attendait peut-être à
tort des déclarations et des
propositions un peu plus étincelantes on
les attendait d'autant plus que chaque
jour le nombre de bateaux de voyageurs
détournés des ports français dans les
ports étrangers de cesse de croître en
fait ce laconisme affiché si l'on peut
dire peut s'expliquer par un double
refus d'abord celui d'augmenter les prix
du gazole et sur ce point là pas
question de céder du reste patrick vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure
la commission de bruxelles vient de
réaffirmer son opposition à toute
subvention du prix du gazole qui déjà en
france est complètement des taxes et
ensuite le gouvernement ne veut pas
paraître céder devant 25000 pêcheurs au
moment même où l'on va rentrer en
période électorale et où de nombreux
signes laissent prévoir des conflits
sociaux assez durs dans les semaines qui
viennent à cet égard la pêche
certes un petit peu de test social et
politique à la retraite le gouvernement
compte donc semble-t-il sur les
discussions sur les propositions faites
hier par monsieur le theule et sur le
plan pêche qu'il avait présenté le 2
avril pour débloquer la situation à
venir celle ci pour le moment apparaît
plus que jamais figé mais on peut se
poser la question de savoir si le
gouvernement fait un bon calcul alors
que cfdt qui sont loin d'être unitaire
dans ce conflit criant au coeur que les
propositions faites par monsieur le
theule sont tout à fait insuffisantes
en tout cas cette situation ne peut pas
s'éterniser parce qu'elle coûte très
cher aux marins aux mareyeurs aux
industriels aux installations portuaires
et en fait également à l'état monsieur
brejnev écrit le 13 août dernier à
vassieux valéry giscard d'estaing phl
mero un soviétique évoque dans ce
message une éventuelle négociation entre
l'urss et les etats-unis sur la question
des armes nucléaires de terrain c'est à
dire les armes nucléaires tactiques et
probablement la bombe à neutrons
monsieur bakhtiar a changé d adresse
je ne voudrais pas sa nouvelle adresse
après l'attentât dont il avait été
victime le 18 juillet et qui avait causé
la mort de deux personnes l'ancien
premier ministre iranien a décidé de
quitter neuilly la police et ses voisins
souhaitait ce départ monsieur bakhtiar a
loué une maison ce qu'ils soient plus
faciles à protéger la hausse des prix
pour juillet elle sera de 1 5% le
chiffre sera rendu public demain
depuis le début de l'année pour les sept
premiers mois la hausse des prix frôle
les 8 et demi pour cent moscou juge le
parti socialiste monsieur françois
mitterrand se place à l'extrême droite
de l'éventail politique français c'est
l'hebdomadaire temps nouveau à
l'hebdomadaire moscovite qui le dit la
revue qualifie monsieur mitterrand de
défenseur de la politique militariste de
l'otan et d'avocats de l'accentuation de
la tension dans les relations
internationales
nouveau signe de tension chez renault à
boulogne billancourt la cgt la cfdt
appelle à un arrêt de travail de deux
heures vendredi matin
motif de cette grève le licenciement du
délégué cgt de boulogne billancourt et
les craintes que suscite le plan de
modernisation de cette usine en
angleterre et pour la première fois
depuis près de 50 ans le cap des 2
millions de chômeurs vient d'être
dépassé l'angleterre compte très
exactement 2 millions 1208 chaume enfin
la chine
ça bouge à pékin l'évolution politique
de l'après maoïsme semble s'accélérer
d'habitude ce genre de changement
d'orientation se fait par toute petite
touche aujourd'hui à pékin
c'est le spectaculaire qui l'a emporté
70 76 la chine pleurs motte et tous ceux
des plus à figer et même ceux qui
militaient très fort pour le changement
tout cela ne pouvait croire ou espérer
moins que presque quatre ans après la
mort de mao qu'on ferait disparaître
portrait
et pourtant tout cela s'est passé
presque dans l'indifférence quel symbole
que de voir poser à terre la photo de
celui dont on disait que contrairement à
la lune et au soleil sa pensée si paris
s'est jamais l'enlèvement des portraits
de mao tsé toung quelques jours avant
l'ouverture de la session plénière de
l'assemblée nationale populaire chinoise
est un signe qui montre bien que les
remaniements de fond souhaitait par
dengue sont sur le point d'aboutir
le changement le plus important serait
que roy cophan quitte ses fonctions de
premier ministre
il serait remplacé par monsieur yao ming
liang l'un des bras droits et à plus
long terme d'haïti hopping prendrait lui
sa retraite après qu'il ait pris
l'assurance que celle une politique
pragmatique ne soit plus remise en
question alors ces jeunes chinois
risquent de ne plus entendre parler de
la pensée le tour de france à la voile
les bateaux sont restés dans le port de
bormes les mimosas aujourd'hui
impossible de sortir il y avait trop de
vent de l'autre côté de l'atlantique le
bateau du baron bich france 3 lui juste
le vent qu'il lui fallait opposer dans
la coupe de l'america au bateau
britannique live earth france 3 l'a
finalement emporté par quatre régates à
2 54 secondes pour une portion de
paradis le grand rêve du baron bich est
en train de se réaliser
france 3 après avoir accédé à la finale
des challenger n'a plus qu'un obstacle à
franchir pour défier enfin les
américains malgré cet abordage qui
faillit coûter la victoire au français
sur le tapis vert s'est assez facilement
que france 3 a dominé la dernière régate
les réclamations de lionheart ne servir
à rien
pour la première fois depuis dix ans
l'un des voiliers du baron bic va donc
tenter d'être le premier 12 mètres
français a rencontré les détenteurs du
trophée
auparavant il va falloir et ce dès
vendredi battre l'autre prétendant à la
superfinale le bateau australien
australia large vainqueur du suédois
seriez
demain leurs antennes 2010 à 12h45 donc
nous allons parler du littoral français
les vacances se terminent et cette année
on a beaucoup évoqué encore
l'entassement et la surpopulation sur
les côtes françaises et certains se
posent même des questions sur la survie
des plus beaux sites alors délai
grandclément qui se trouve à
sainte-maxime recevra demain midi
monsieur andré lançons qui préside
l'union régionale nature et puis
monsieur michel d'ornano répondra aux
questions que l'on se pose mais silence
inquiète pour le littoral sur la côte
méditerranéenne
on s'inquiète aussi beaucoup pour la
maire marie aude génère l'infime
français a obtenu le premier prix au
festival du film scientifique réalisée
par jean baud ce film s'intitule
pollutions et nuisances sur le littoral
méditerranéen des images accablantes un
premier prix pour un film magnifique
mais aussi un peu terrifiant ce film
scientifique montre les dégâts de la
pollution surtout humaine mais aussi son
évolution la désertification sous marine
de la côte d'azur est catastrophique
parce que cette bande du littoral est à
la base de la chaîne alimentaire de tout
le milieu marin ces algues filamenteuses
ne servent à rien elles sont moins utile
qu'un seul alors dans ce cloaque seul
subsiste et pullulent
quelques rares espèces qui ne sont pas
gênés par les polluants
c'est le cas de ces étoiles de mer que
l'on appelle des eaux sûres et toiles
qui ne présage rien de bon
puisqu'elles ont remplacé un herbier qui
non seulement oxygénée l'eau mais
étaient nécessaires à la vie marine
alors la méditerranée et elles mort
heureusement pas encore mais il était
grand temps que les pays riverains
s'entendent pour arriver à la ceni
la france pour sa part a lancé un
programme de dix ans pour éliminer la
pollution sur la côte d'azur
mais on le voit sur ces images il faudra
plus que cela pour que la vie
sous-marine redevienne normale il y à 25
ans cette zone était considéré comme
très riche mais sans pollution
il faudra des dizaines d'années et des
dizaines d'années pour retrouver un
aspect normal
le jour où l'herbier de posidonie ces
herbes qui apporte de l'oxygène dans
l'eau remplaceront ces bêtes affreuse
que sont les oxyures la bataille sera
gagné mais ce sera long
le propose maintenant de terminer cette
édition sur un triomphe celui de deux
français il ne s'agit pas de sport cela
se passait hier soir à beyrouth pendant
une heure et demie les fanatiques de
wagner ont ovationné hier soir pierre
boulez et patrice chéreau 90 minutes
d'applaudissements 107 rappel c'était la
dernière représentation de la tétralogie
et pour la première fois une caméra
celle d'antenne de pénétrer à bayreuth
georges bigot vient d'ailleurs de
rencontrer patrick chiron 85 minutes
d'applaudissements s'en rappelle alors
dans quel état vous êtes vous senti hier
comment avez vous appréhendé ce triomphe
oui ça fait ça fait je vais pas avoir
l'air dégoûté non plus ça fait toujours
plaisir évidemment mais ce qui me semble
important c'est que c'est que l'on soit
quand même finalement arrivés au bout de
ce qu'on voulait avec avec ce spectacle
c'est de dire que en cinq ans n'e réussi
à faire d'abord à convaincre le public
byron ensuite à le changer même en
partie et que je suis arrivé qu'on soit
arrivé pierre boulez et moi faire que le
spectacle existe qui existe comme on le
voulait vous avez eu des difficultés ça
veut dire tout bayrou c'est quelque
chose de très particulier est ce qu'on
peut l'expliquer rapidement oui bah et
redonner quelque chose de particulier
parce que il y a depuis très longtemps
toujours une sorte de culte de wagner
comme ça qui est inculte exagéré
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon les
algues équivoque que qu'ont provoqué
cette mise en scène les sifflets et tout
ça était exagérée de même une certaine
façon le le succès actuel est aussi
exagéré en partie je veux dire que ce
qui est intéressant dans bayrou c'est
que d'un endroit qui était entre
guillemets un temple d'un endroit qui
était qu'ils étaient voués à peu au
culte de bagues nerfs et depuis l'ain
depuis l'après guerre
finalement les héritiers de wagner en
ont fait un théâtre on part en parfait
ordre de marche à laquelle on peut
expérimenter des choses d'en faire selon
leurs propres termes un atelier c'est
d'abord un très très beau théâtre un nom
un bâtiment magnifique avec une
acoustique parfaite et cet intérêt dans
lequel on peut vraiment travailler se
concentrer sur un spectacle et faire que
ce spectacle avec jusqu'au bout de
l'idée qu'on essaye de lui
et de lui insuffler peu de gens
assistent au spectacle de byron et pour
cause les places sont prises en ahl
avance alors une vague nerf ça a
pourtant une actualité qui intéresse
tout le monde
oui je plus daguenet c'est une actualité
je crois je dirais pas clair ce ne sont
pas des opéras comme les autres
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya qui est né ce sont
7 une ce sont des histoires formidables
qui sert a conquis son raconté ce sont
des histoires qui parlent de légende qui
partent de l'histoire du 19e siècle et
ce sont des choses qui nous parle nous
profondément c'est plus que de la
musique c'est plus que de l'eau perrin
c'est plus que du théâtre c'est un
mélange à mon avis particulièrement
réussie
il
m
oui
et
brice deux minutes de beyrouth seulement
ce soir mais c'était pour vous donner un
avant goût et vous demander de prendre
un peu patience si nos caméras étaient
avérés de cette année c'était pour
enregistrer l'ensemble de la tétralogie
et cet ensemble de programmes sera
diffusée en 1980 sur antenne 2 il y aura
un kart et demain à deauville cela se
passera dans le prix de sa scie alors
qu'ils restent basses m'a téléphoné ces
derniers favoris gré impérial le dise
at-il à 1 le 1 asti flag 6 thomas le
sais tu pas vino le 13 lowe's le 8
ferragu le 2 et give aph
le 3 est aussi un tirage du loto
aujourd'hui je vous en donne rapidement
les résultats le 18 le 24 le 31 le 36 le
45 le 48 numéro complémentaire le 28
j'espère que vous êtes nombreux à avoir
trouvé ses différents numéros la météo
température moyenne aujourd'hui sur la
france
je vous laisse rapidement consulter les
chiffres demain les plus orageuses vont
affecter les vosges le jura et le sud
est de la france il y aura du brouillard
au lever du jour mais dans l'après midi
le temps sera ensoleillé sauf dans
l'extrême sud-est où des pluies
orageuses pourraient persister
les températures seront à peu près
semblable à celle d'aujourd'hui
c'est paul amar qui vous présentera
notre dernière édition à 23h20 demain
pour antenne 2010 je vous le rappelle
nous serons à sainte-maxime nous
parlerons du sauvetage du littoral
bonne soirée à demain